in our series the new normal we look at
how the pandemic is dramatically
changing
our everyday lives this morning how an
ancient setting was turned into a safe
performance space
centuries ago rome's circus maximus was
where romans gathered to watch
chariot races today in the era of social
distancing chris livesay shows
us how modern romans are heading there
once again
for a night at the opera
the art form is synonymous with italy
but the setting is out of place and time
more than 2 000 years ago it was chariot
races that drew romans here to the
circus
maximus today it's opening night of
verdi's rigoletto
reinterpreted with a 1970s setting
but the audience is unmistakably from
2020
safely seated more than six feet apart
something the rome opera couldn't
achieve inside its concert hall
or at its smaller outdoor venue
soprano rosa feola says the circus
maximus
spanning more than two football fields
is a godsend
it's been four months that we are not
allowed to sing
in theaters because it's not safe place
so
we was waiting for this moment to come
back to the life
again so i feel like a very young young
young singer
again a young singer in an
old place with a history of charismatic
performers
[Music]
now picture it this is the same
racetrack where emperor nero himself
would
race chariot before 150 000
screaming romans now today because of
social distancing and coronavirus
it's only 1500 spectators here at the
opera
seeing verdi in such a historic setting
is moving after all these months in
lockdown
says one opera goer
is life you know and we need to live and
we need
the art even the set was designed with
social distancing in mind
when you have the the energy to go
through a person you have a car
in the middle so you remember that you
have not to go the other side with the
singing with the music
you can give emotions even if we are not
touching if there's going to be a second
act
even opera can adapt
for cbs this morning chris livesay roam
gosh you heard that piece i want to hear
more yeah i know it's so great to see a
live performance if it takes parking
cars on the stage to keep people apart
great whatever works being creative